[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview notre
invité et fabien roussel secrétaire
nationale du parti communiste français
et député du nord bonjour
fabien roussel merci d'avoir accepté
cette grande interview sur rtl france
alors fabien roussel y ait un changement
de stratégie au niveau de votre parti
puisqu'il y aura peut-être à une
candidature pour la présidentielle ce
sera peut-être vous on va y venir
ça veut dire qu' il n'y aura pas comme
en 2012 et en 2017 une alliance avec
jean luc mélenchon
d'abord est ce que c'est vous qui est à
l'initiative de ce virage à 180 degrés
d'abord il ya un débat qui est ouvert au
sein de ma formation politique et nous
allons prendre cette décision dans les
semaines qui viennent
le débat est ouvert ce que nous
proposons c'est de construire un pacte
avec les français pour bousculer tous
les pronostics de cette élection
présidentielle 2022
nous voulons reconstruire une force une
force à gauche qui ouvre des
perspectives pour le monde du travail
pour la jeunesse et nous voulons en même
temps pouvoir construire un pacte aussi
pour les élections législatives et crée
les conditions d'une majorité de gauche
et écologistes à l'assemblée nationale
avec bien sûr en son sein le plus de
députés communistes possible c'est le
débat qui est ouvert qui se conclura par
un vote des adhérents le 9 mai prochain
mais à votre niveau est ce que vous vous
êtes favorable vous êtes ouverts ou
fermés à la france insoumise et à jean
luc mélenchon alors d'abord je suis
ouvert à tous les échanges et à toutes
les discussions et est donc c'est pas
comme ça que ça se pose la question
personnellement je considère que nous
avons vocation à pouvoir participer à ce
grand débat qui est l'élection
présidentielle et a incarné à proposer
une issue à notre pays au peuple de
france
il y à une crise économique une et crise
sanitaire sans précédent qui bouscule
l'humanité qui bouscule aussi notre pays
le monde du travail paye cher le coût de
cette crise nous disons que ce n'est pas
au monde du travail de payer cette crise
les richesses dans notre pays sont
énormes
elles ont besoin d'être mises au service
du peuple et de ceux qui travaillent et
nous voulons nous attaquer à l'évasion
fiscale nous voulons reprendre le
pouvoir la finance pour toutes ces
raisons oui le parti communiste français
souhaitent pouvoir incarner
l'alternative le changement l'espoir est
pour ma part je je suis convaincu de
cela et je souhaite pouvoir défendre nos
propositions à l'occasion de cette
élection présidentielle tient il va
regarder cet espoir à gauche
il ya un débat au sein du parti
communiste c'est vrai mais vous à votre
niveau finalement qu'est ce que vous
vous dites vous dites qu'il faut y aller
tout seul à cette élection
présidentielle et ne pas recommencer les
alliances du passé avec la france
insoumise
d'abord le débat a lieu chez nous j'ai
livré mon état d'esprit et je vous le
redis je suis moi convaincu que nous
devons pouvoir y aller pour faire part
de nos propositions et convaincre un
maximum de nos concitoyens qu'il est
urgentissime de sortir de ce modèle
économique qui privilégie l'argent la
rentabilité à tout prix alors que nous
nous voulons mettre au coeur de tous les
choix
l'être humain et la planète ces deux
urgences sociales et écologiques sont
les deux pieds sur lesquels nous voulons
marcher à l'occasion de cette élection
présidentielle et de ces élections
législatives justement donc que nous
voulons aller avec cette ambition là il
va falloir peser pour ces élections on
se souvient que les deux dernières
alliance avec la france insoumis je me
permets d'insister ont ramené 4 et puis
7 millions de voix et vous savez très
bien qu'il faut remonter très loin pour
voir de tels scores au niveau du parti
communiste français il faut remonter à
mai 1981 avec le georges marchais et
l'union que nous souhaitons construire
c'est l'union du peuple de france
c'est l'union des françaises et des
français qui aspirent à reprendre le
pouvoir sur l'argent sur la finance pour
les mettre au service de nos modes de
production de notre souveraineté
économique de pouvoir retrouver notre
entière souvent entre dans les choix que
nous voulons faire c'est pouvoir sortir
de ces traités libéraux qui font tant de
mal à notre pays
donc vous
voyez ce que nous souhaitons pouvoir
construire c'est une alliance très large
de tous nos concitoyens et cela se
construit aussi avec le mouvement social
avec les organisations syndicales avec
les associations les ong
avec toutes celles et ceux qui luttent
en ce moment et nous ne voulons pas
fermé la porte de construire aussi cette
union avec des forces politiques de
gauche écologistes et c'est justement
l'appel que nous souhaitons lancer aussi
en 2022 avec les élections législatives
car autant l'élection présidentielle est
un débat où un homme et une femme
présente son projet pour le pays
à l'occasion de cette élection mais six
semaines après il ya des élections
législatives où là il s'agit d'élire les
représentants du peuple et député de la
nation
et là nous devons unir nos forces pour
créer les conditions d'avoir une
majorité à la santé nations avec un
maximum de députés communistes en son
sein mais justement cette proposition
d'une candidature pour 2022
seulement 52% des militants communistes
ont validé la proposition les autres
n'en vois pas l'utilité et c'est vrai
que ça peut se comprendre parce que si
on remonte à la dernière candidature
communiste c'était en 2007 avec marc
george buffet seulement un dingue
93% des voix alors bon on peut toujours
parler de ce qui s'est passé et il y a
près de quinze ans maintenant nous
pensons nous aujourd'hui que nous sommes
dans une situation complètement
différente
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle parce que le
quinquennat de françois hollande a été
dévastateur et puis peut-être aussi
parce que les promesses qui était
incarnée dans le score de jean luc
mélenchon à la dernière élection
présidentielle ne s'est pas traduit
derrière par des rassemblements des
alliances les plus large et donc
justement nous nous voulons redonner un
espoir à gauche
nous souhaitons pouvoir parler à
l'ensemble des électeurs
indépendamment d'ailleurs des choix
qu'ils ont pu faire lors des précédentes
élections nous souhaitons parler avant
tout à toutes celles et ceux qui n'y
croient plus qu'ils s'abstiennent
aujourd'hui voyez il ya énormément de
français aujourd'hui qu'ils ne veulent
plus aller voter alors que la solution
aller chez eux dans leur bulle
va dans leur volonté d'exprimer leur
choix de sortir de ce système économique
qui broie les êtres humains et donc la
candidature que je souhaite incarner
c'est celle là c'est celle qui redonne
de l'espoir à gauche qui va être
bienveillante et qui va aussi porter un
nouveau souffle à gauche dont nous avons
tant besoin puisque vous parlez de ce
nouveau souffle à gauche
cela s'inscrit dans un rassemblement en
tout cas c'est ce que vous nous
expliquer donc on a du mal à comprendre
l'idée d'une candidature communiste
parce que vous prenez le risque quand
même six et validé au final par votre
parti de faire de la figuration et en
conséquence d'affaiblir un peu plus le
parti communiste
si les résultats ne sont pas au rendez
vous mais je vois que je vois que vous
avez envie d'insister lourdement sur le
sujet mais je vais y répondre encore une
fois avec un autre argument d'abord vous
pointez la question de la division des
candidatures à gauche et donc ça ne
s'adresse pas seulement au parti
communiste français
cette question là elle peut être posée à
toutes les autres candidatures et
ensuite voyez vous aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir l'emporter à cette élection
il ne s'agit pas d'additionner des
forces qui aujourd'hui sont faibles ce
qui est important c'est de pouvoir
convainc un plus grand nombre de nos
concitoyens à pouvoir voter pour des
forces de gauche et que cette addition
deviennent majoritaires demain or
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien que
l'addition des forces de gauche ou des
candidatures ne fait pas une majorité
loin de là ça ne permettrait peut-être
même pas d'être présent au second tour
il ya donc le véritable défi c'est
d'aller convaincre beaucoup plus
d'électeurs d'avoir une force et une
personnalité et qui incarne
véritablement un renouveau à gauche et
qui redonne de l'espoir et c'est ce que
je souhaite pouvoir incarner aujourd'hui
la gauche n'est pas faible de ses
divisions
elle est faible surtout parce qu'elle a
déçu et qu'elles ne portent pas d'espoir
je souhaite pouvoir moi retisser ce lien
avec une grande majorité de nos
concitoyens à partir de propositions que
nous allons porter et donc je ne
souhaite pas que dès maintenant on nous
dise et bien vous n'avez pas le droit de
présenter votre candidature de quel
droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire ça
les scellés
c'est décidé laissez les français ceux
qui ne votent plus qu'ils ne sont plus
convaincus de l'utilité des élections
est bien de pouvoir faire leur choix
c'est assez méprisant d'ailleurs de leur
dire et bien tel parti n'a pas vocation
à se présenter car il ajoute à la
division laisser les français décider et
c'est comme ça que l'on pourra redonner
du sens à la démocratie au niveau de vos
militants c'est vrai qu'il ya une
volonté aussi de voir une réelle
représentation sein de l'hémicycle en
2022 vous faisait allusion législatif
puisque à cette proposition
ce pâtes ou d'engagement aux autres
forces de gauche pour vous c'est quoi
finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle parce que vous savez pour
beaucoup de vos militants
l'idée c'est de privilégier cette
représentation au sein de l'hémicycle au
détriment de la candidature
on parle même d'un retrait éventuel
alors non nous avons mis dans le texte
qui est aujourd'hui au débat dans notre
dans ma formation politique dans ce
texte bien sûr nous voulons lier
intimement ces deux élections car elles
sont intimement liés malheureusement
depuis que le calendrier électoral a été
bougé il ya les élections
présidentielles et six semaines après
des élections législatives et cela tous
les cinq ans et donc les élections
législatives elles sont importantes
elles sont importantes aussi parce que
le parlement l'assemblée nationale c'est
là où siègent les députés du peuple les
représentants du peuple et que c'est la
somme de ces députés qui peuvent former
une majorité
c'est bien pourquoi nous voulons nous
pouvoir construire dans les 577
circonscriptions de notre pays les
conditions de faire élire le plus de
députés communistes et le plus de
députés issus de la gauche et de
l'écologie
car ce sera important pour construire
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale
quel que soit le choix des français
d'ailleurs à l'élection présidentielle
sion et donc c'est le débat que nous
voulons porter au sein des adhérents
mais vous dites pas de négociations pas
de vous dit pas de négociations pas de
retrait avant la présidentielle en vue
de sceller leur actif
j'ai paraît j'ai effectivement pas
répondu à votre question
si je suis désignée par mes amis
à l'élection présidentielle bien sûr
cette candidature c'est pour aller
jusqu'au bout c'est surtout pas pour la
retirer en fonction de telle ou telle
négociation c'est pas l'objet nous avons
nous présentons une candidature nous
voulons présenter une candidature à
l'élection présidentielle pour non
seulement participer à ce débat mais
pour un corps incarnez un changement est
un espoir pour pouvoir être présent dans
le futur gouvernement ou ou dans la
future majorité qui présidera aux
destinées du pays donc c'est pour gagner
que nous voulons aller à l'élection
présidentielle donc surtout pas pour
retirer une candidature avant la fin en
fonction de quelques négociations que ce
soit mais nous voulons en même temps
pouvoir discuter des élections
législatives et pouvoir entamer un
dialogue avec l'ensemble des forces de
gauche
les deux peuvent tenir en même temps
d'ailleurs j'ai entendu que d'autres
forces de gauche lancé ce même appel à
pouvoir construire cet échange que ce
soit jean luc mélenchon ou où que ce
soit au parti socialiste est bien
discutons-en entamant ces discussions au
niveau des législatives et respectons
chaque forces politiques qui souhaitent
présenter un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya un débat qui
s'est cristallisé autour justement de
cette affiche marine le pen à emmanuel
macron au second tour de cette
présidentielle il ya un sondage récent
paru chez marianne qui montre que le
front républicain qui s'effrite chez les
insoumis un petit peu moins chez les
écologistes et est là la france est
justement les socialistes vous qu'est ce
que vous ferez ce que vous appellerai à
faire barrage au rassemblement national
y compris face à emmanuel macron d'abord
permettez moi de vous dire que je trouve
particulièrement méprisant pour nos
concitoyens de leur dire déjà ce que
sera le second tour de cette élection
présidentielle franchement cette petite
musique là elle est fatigante et
déprimante pour la démocratie
enfin il ya une élection à deux tours ou
au premier tour chaque partie chaque
candidat présente son programme et
ensuite au second tour on se rassemble
pour éliminer celui que l'on ne veut pas
et donc laisser faire le premier tour et
laisser chaque candidat présenté son
programme et laisser les français
choisir
ce qu'il préfère enfin quand même c'est
quand même incroyable aujourd'hui de
dire que le second jeudi en ciel ce sera
déjà macron et et le pen mais enfin de
commandes est inscrite une affaire
aujourd'hui second tour alors mai mais
enfin bce mais comment comment peut-on
faire aujourd'hui des sondages en disant
que macron sera présent au second tour
alors qu'on ne sait même pas s'il sera
en capacité de se présenter tellement la
politique qu'il a mise en oeuvre en
faveur des plus riches et contre la
majorité de nos concitoyens est
aujourd'hui décriée par la population
enfin et nous et nous et vous déjà mais
pas le vous dit on il sera là dénonce
vautours donc je voudrais tu n'es pas là
mais je vous raconte fabienne la peine
si elle passe au second tour que ce soit
face à emmanuel ma maison un autre
candidat par exemple oui mais vous voyez
jeu avant de parler du second tour je
préfère toujours parler du premier tour
et donc je préfère parler de ce que nous
souhaitons pour les veuves portée lors
du premier tour de cette élection
présidentielle et puis j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer contre un
éventuel second tour aux élections
présidentielles qui verrait un
représentant de l'extrême droite
française présente et bien je le dis
comme je les dis à chaque fois
jamais le parti communiste français
laissera l'extrême droite présidé aux
destinées de notre pays jamais parce que
ce sont c'est dans nos gènes
nous sommes le parti issu de la
résistance et cela nous ne laisserons
jamais faire et donc pour cela justement
pour empêcher ce pronostic pour empêcher
ce duel que tout le monde veut déjà nous
mettre sous d'entre eux n'est justement
nous disons et nous appelons et
j'appelle les français à participer
massivement au premier tour de cette
élection est de faire en sorte que ni
macro ni le pen soit présent lors de ce
second tour
et c'est justement par le vote qu'ils
feront premier tour qu'ils peuvent
changer
ce pronostic est ce duel et donc c'est
le premier tour qui est important et pas
l'issue du second
fabien roussel on va marquer une courte
pause et se retrouver pour poursuivre
cet entretien avec vous restez avec nous
sur rt france
[Musique]
un retour dans la grande interview avec
fabien roussel secrétaire nationale du
parti communiste et député du nord
sabah roussel il ya une échéance des
échéances importantes qui vont peut-être
faire figure de test d'ailleurs en vue
de cette présidentielle que l'on évoqué
ce sont les régionales et
départementales en juin l'exécutif fait
allusion à un report de ces élections
les présidents des régions ne veulent
pas en entendre parler
est ce que vous êtes favorable à un
report de ces élections
bon d'abord la démocratie doit pouvoir
s'exprimer même en période de pandémie
et donc c'est la première chose que j'ai
envie de dire c'est que dans beaucoup de
pays dans la majorité des pays la
pandémie n'a pas empêché des élections
mais en même temps je me souviens que
lors du premier tour des élections
municipales
l'année dernière beaucoup de français on
regrettait le maintien du premier tour
et le second tour à d'ailleurs été
reporté parce que il ne se tenait pas
dans de bonnes conditions et les
français ne comprenait pas qu'il soit
obligé de rester chez eux et en même
temps tenus d'aller voter et donc je ne
souhaiterais pas que à l'occasion de ces
élections régionales et départementales
qui sont des élections importantes qu'il
y ait un taux d'abstention tellement
élevé que cette élection aurait plus de
sens en fait et donc nous devons avoir
le temps de pouvoir mener campagne
nous devons avoir le temps de pouvoir
aller rencontrer nos concitoyens et
parler de nos projets de nos programmes
de nos idées sinon nous n'allons pas les
intéresser à cette élection leur montrer
que c'est important et donc c'est un peu
ce que nous demandons aujourd'hui c'est
de pouvoir mener campagne
si nous ne pouvons pas mener campagne
s'il est impossible si ce gouvernement
ne crée pas les conditions que nous
puissions mener campagne alors oui la
question du report doit pouvoir être
posée parce que ce que je souhaite
d'abord c'est que les français puissent
pouvoir aller voter en ayant
connaissance des programmes de chaque
lycée de chaque candidat vous étiez prêt
vous amener une liste face à xavier
bertrand a mené liste de rassemblement
de gauche pour ces régionales en juin
dans le nord bon il ya eu cet accord
votre parti le parti socialiste elle est
si les écologistes
derrière l'eurodéputée écologiste karima
delli ce qu'est une pointe d'amertume ou
alors vous adhérez réellement à 1000% à
cet accord bon d'abord je suis moi très
attaché à ma région que j'aime j'y suis
né et j'y mourrai et je continue d'y
vivre et je suis très attaché à voir ce
lien direct avec les habitants de ma
région pour défendre son industrie pour
l'engager dans la transition écologique
pour permettre à chacune et chacun de
pouvoir vivre dignement avec son travail
et avec de bonnes retraites quand on a
passé une vie à travailler ça c'est mon
combat mon combat pour la dignité
humaine ce combat pour ma région je
continuerai de le mener et j'ai toujours
dit que je souhaitais qu'il y ait une
liste de très large rassemblement aux
élections régionales afin de pouvoir
mettre en échec la politique très
libéral du président très libérale
xavier bertrand qui lui envisage par
exemple de privatiser nos ter alors
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que j'ai
abordé les discussions avec l'ensemble
des forces de gauche et écologistes
il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui nous
arrivons à nous mettre tous d'accord
autour de la liste de karima delli
moi j'avais mis ma candidature à
disposition et j'étais prêt à tirer
cette liste bien sûr les priorités que
j'aurais porté en tant que communistes
sont différentes de celles que va porter
karima delli
mais c'est pas moi qui décide c'est
aussi le choix des autres forces
politiques et j'ai vu que la france
soumise par exemple préféré se rallier à
karima delli plutôt qu'à ma candidature
dont tact ça c'est un principe de
réalité
donc je fais avec pc le rassemblement
d'abord c'est donc ça qui doit
aujourd'hui nous guider donc je soutiens
ce rassemblement mais je lance un appel
je profite de votre antenne pour le dire
je lance un appel pour que dans la
région normandie le même choix se fasse
autour de la candidature de mon camarade
sébastien jumel qui pourrait demain être
la tête de liste réunissant les
communistes les insoumis les écologistes
et les socialistes et donc six mois j'ai
été capable de faire cet effort dans les
hauts de france
j'aimerais bien que mes amis écologistes
et socialistes fassent la même chose
derrière la candidature de sébastien
jumel avec un an c'est qu'en 2015 y
avait un retrait en faveur de xavier
bertrand justement en contre
le rassemblement national cette fois le
scénario possible
imaginons l'objectif c'est que nous
soyons en tête de cette élection c'est
tout simplement ça c'est en tête à
l'issue du premier tour
encore une fois s'il vous plaît ne nous
fait pas le coup du second tour avant
d'avoir joué le premier la l'ensemble
des forces de gauche font le choix de
s'unir aux élections départementales
comme aux élections régionales et
l'objectif c'est de créer une dynamique
ensemble pour pouvoir arriver en tête et
donc me demandez pas ce qu'on fera si on
arrive troisième ou quatrième c'est pal
c'est pas un scénario que nous
envisageons nous envisageons la vie soir
donc je ne parlerais et je ne
commenterai que ce scénario là fabien
roussel selon un sondage harris
interactive pour la fédération
hospitalière de france
la santé sera un enjeu prioritaire en
2022 au même niveau qu'au l'emploi très
impactées par la pandémie et deux ans
même les questions de sécurité le
terrorisme et l'éducation
est-ce que ça correspond au projet que
vous portez pour sortir justement de
cette crise oui et mille fois oui parce
que avant cette crise sanitaire nous
étions à côté des blouses blanches qui
manifestait déjà dès l'année 2018 contre
la pénurie de moyens
la pénurie d'argent public pour défendre
les hôpitaux publics pour défendre des
hôpitaux de proximité pour qu'il y en
ait partout dans nos campagnes comme
dans les grandes villes comme dans les
grands comme dans les banlieues
nous militions pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux
et tout cela nécessite beaucoup d'argent
public or à l'époque le président de la
république nous répondait et il n'y a
pas d'argent magique et ce n'était pas
possible eh bien cette crise a montré
que quand il faut y mettre les moyens
eh bien le gouvernement s'est en trouver
des moyens et il y a eu un peu d'argent
public a été investi dans nos hôpitaux
pas assez à notre goût mais quand même
alors oui la question de la santé
publique est une question qui sera
central à l'occasion des présidentielles
et des législatives 2022 la santé n'est
pas une marchandise et nous allons
défendre nous une proposition forte pour
remettre en place dans notre pays un
système de santé publique à la hauteur
vous savez le parti communiste français
a été à l'origine de la création de la
sécurité sociale dans notre pays en 45
c'est la même ambition que nous devons
avoir pour notre pays aujourd'hui en
2021 c'est d'avoir un système de santé
capable de protéger tous nos concitoyens
de la maladie et leur permettre un accès
aux soins en tous points de notre
territoire
eh bien ça ça va nécessiter de faire de
grandes réformes et de faire en sorte
que beaucoup d'argent public soit
investi dans notre système de santé
publique pour contrer la troisième vague
épidémique un troisième confinement dans
votre région le nord mais aussi en ile
de france
comment vous jugez les mesures prises et
bien écoutez nous regrettons tout
simplement qu'il n'y a enfin pour ma
part je vais vous dire parce que il ya
beaucoup d'avis il ya autant d'avis que
deux personnes que l'on interroge moi
pour ma part je regrette qu'il n'y ait
pas eu de dispositions qui était éprise
avant je regrette que l'on ait gâché le
mois de février où les écoles étaient
fermées et on aurait pu profiter
peut-être pour prendre des mesures afin
d'éviter que l'épidémie s'affole et
qu'elle devienne incontrôlable
aujourd'hui le nombre de conduites
contamination est tellement important
que cela en devient incontrôlable
alors le couvert de toiles à woippy
n'est finalement 11 qui n'en est pas un
il aurait fallu qu'on signer avant anti
si moi je suis plutôt partisan je suis
plutôt partisan de la stratégie zéro co
vide c'est à dire de créer toutes les
conditions pour que nous atteignons un
taux de contamination suffisamment bas
pour pouvoir permettre de lutter
d'empêcher l'épidémie de pouvoir
circulez dans notre pays ou dans des
régions cette stratégie mise en place
dans d'autres pays du monde
et d'ailleurs l'union européenne aurait
pu décider de mettre en place cette
stratégie à l'échelle de l'union
européenne est de protéger nos
frontières pour empêcher l'épidémie d'y
rentrer de circuler et et donc de
pouvoir la contenir maintenant on en est
là aujourd'hui la seule solution qui
vaille aujourd'hui c'est une politique
de vaccination massive et c'est le
combat que je mène avec mes camarades
parlementaire du sénat de l'assemblée
nationale c'est d'obtenir que la france
se bat à l'organisation mondiale du
commerce pour la levée des brevets la
propriété intellectuelle qui pèsent
aujourd'hui sur les vaccins ce sont des
l'indus et l'industrie pharmaceutique
c'est compliqué pour deux pour oc pour
ça pour obtenir cette levée des brevets
sans doute parce que les groupes
pharmaceutiques ne souhaite pas vraiment
comment est-ce qu'on peut forcer ces
groupes à le faire a levé les brevets
vous imaginez bien qu'aujourd'hui vous
rendez compte que l'industrie
pharmaceutique aujourd'hui protège ses
intérêts financiers protège le taux de
rentabilité exigée par ses actionnaires
et qu'au nom de cela ils ne veulent pas
levé les brevets ils font de cette
pandémie ses actionnaires parmi lesquels
je vais citer blackrock ce que blackrock
est un des actionnaires membres de tous
les grands industriels pharmaceutiques
qui ont qui ont aujourd'hui des vaccins
et bien au nom de cela ils font de la
pandémie
une opportunité économique mais c'est
particulièrement scandaleux
enfin c'est aujourd'hui et nous devrions
mettre briffaud fléchois mais pour
changer la donne
qu'est-ce-qui sofa mais j'y viens j'y
viens c'est une lutte mondiale
planétaire que nous devons mener contre
ce vaccin et faire en sorte que ces
vaccins deviennent des biens publics
ils ne peuvent pas être entre les mains
d'intérêts privés et donc pour cela nous
demandons à ce que les connaissances des
différents laboratoires soient partagées
et à ce que chaque pays puisse produire
dans son pays
les vaccins dont il a besoin c'est ce
que demande l'afrique du sud
c'est ce que demande l'inde c'est ce que
demande des dizaines de pays qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas accès aux vaccins
eh bien il faut qu'il puisse le produire
librement chez eux
je ne parle pas du flaconnage je parle
de la possibilité de produire les
vaccins en échange d'une indemnité
versée à l'industrie pharmaceutique et
ça l'om c'est le permet dans son code du
commerce international c'est l'article
31 quand il y à une urgence sanitaire 1
étape demander la levée des brevets pour
pouvoir produire dans son pays les
médicaments ou les vaccins dont il a
besoin et cela s'est déjà produit dans
l'histoire de l'humanité est ce que vous
trouvez normal que la france suive comme
l'allemagne et les recommandations de
l'agencé européenne du médicament pour
justement décidé la poursuite ou non du
vaccin astrazeneca alors que le royaume
uni c'est vrai qu'ils aient sortir de
l'union européenne ne l'a pas retiré au
motif du bénéfice bien plus élevé que le
risque je cite le royaume uni mais je
pourrais citer d'autres pays par exemple
qui sont font partie de l'union
européenne comme la hongrie qui ont opté
pour d'autres vaccins vaccin russes par
exemple scouts nick v et le vaccin
chinois aussi jeu
je pense que d'abord il faut susciter de
l'adhésion et de la confiance dans les
vaccins et donc suite aux cas de
thrombose qu'il y a eu il fallait
peut-être prendre le temps quelques
jours pour pouvoir dire aux français
voilà ça a été étudiée voilà les
chiffres et au final nous pouvons avoir
confiance dans ce vaccin et quand je
vois qu'il y a eu de mémoire près de 20
millions de personnes vaccinées avec
l'astra zeneca et qu'il ya dans le monde
et qu'il ya aujourd'hui 18 cas de
thrombose
on peut dire que le bénéfice risque et
et santé il est quand même al'avantage
de la santé et donc je partage l'avis
qui a été rendue de pouvoir se vacciner
à l'astra zeneca et quand ce sera mon
tour de se faire vacciner et si mon
médecin me propose ce vaccin je le
prendrais et je me ferai vacciner avec
l'astra zeneca j'ai pas de problème avec
ça je suis pour que l'on puisse vacciner
massivement
je suis aussi pour que l'on puisse
vacciner massivement les professions qui
sont en première ligne
je pense à ceux qui travaillent dans les
grandes surfaces sept cent mille dans
notre pays je pense aux soignants 800000
dans notre pays qui aujourd'hui
on court des risques sanitaires en étant
en première ligne il faut aussi leur
permettre de pouvoir avoir accès aux
vaccins et aux vaccins de leur choix
comme ça se fait dans d'autres pays
c'est valable pour nos personnels
soignants et bien ça nous y arriverons
quand il y aura suffisamment de vaccins
pour tout le monde c'est pour ça que
j'en reviens à la question de la levée
des brevets sur les vaccins pour que
l'on puisse les produire librement
et puis il ya des vaccins comme le
spoutnik le vaccin cubain le vaccin
chinois qui aujourd'hui existe sur le
marché pourquoi ne nous ne créons nous
pas les conditions pour qu'ils puissent
aussi être accessibles aux pays de
l'union européenne s'agissant de la
crise économique est ce qu'il faut
maintenir le quoi qu'il en coûte même si
la situation avec la campagne de
vaccination s'améliore d'abord il faut
pouvoir donner une lueur d'espoir aux
français la lueur d'espoir la première
c'est celle de sortir de cette crise et
que tout le monde puisse se faire
vacciner
j'en ai parlé pour moi l'autre lueur
d'espoir c'est de pouvoir dire aux
français que quand ils vont travailler
et bien ils sont protégés et en même
temps qu'ils puissent vivre dignement de
leur travail et je reviens là dessus
parce que la semaine dernière le
gouvernement a proposé une prime aux
salariés
or une prime ça peut répondre à une
préoccupation urgente et du moment mais
ce qui compte surtout et avant tout
c'est d'augmenter les salaires
et quand j'entends parler du quoi qu'il
en coûte
et bien moi je voudrais surtout pouvoir
répondre aux français à ceux qui
travaillent aujourd'hui parfois dans des
conditions difficiles
et bien que le travail qu'ils font soit
correctement rémunéré qu'il puisse vivre
correctement de leur salaire or
aujourd'hui le niveau du smic est
tellement bas dans notre pays qu'il ne
permet pas de vivre dignement et c'est
bien là le gros enjeu de notre pays
c'est de faire en sorte que le travail
nous permettent de vivre ce n'est pas le
cas et donc s'il ya bien une politique
du quoi qu'il en coûte à mettre en
oeuvre
c'est celle qui permettra de rémunérer
correctement chaque salarié en lui
permettant d'accéder un contrat à durée
indéterminée à mettre fin au travail
précaire au temps partiel et à garantir
un véritable salaire pour permettre à
chacun d éduquer ses enfants d'avoir
accès aux cultures
ala loisirs aux loisirs au sport et de
vivre dignement
alors si la proposition d'une
candidature pour 2022 et validé par vos
militants vous serez peut-être le
candidat investi ce que vous serez
favorable à l'instauration d'un revenu
universel et si oui sous quelles
conditions et qu'ils seraient éligibles
c'est une proposition qui est de benoît
hamon on s'en souvient qui est un flop
alors écoutez si je suis retenu par ma
formation politique pour être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
et si les français me font confiance et
que je suis le candidat de la gauche qui
arrive à rassembler et qui accède à
l'elysée
eh bien je préfère moi mettre en oeuvre
et ce sera une de mes propositions
phares au mettre en oeuvre une
proposition qui garantisse à chacun un
travail et un salaire plutôt que de
garantir à chacun un revenu universel
qui pour moi s'apparente plutôt à une
forme de rsa une allocation attribués y
compris quand on ne travaille pas
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de
réindustrialiser notre pays nous avons
besoin de services publics efficaces
humains et d'embaucher beaucoup dans nos
services de santé dans nos écoles dans
nos services publics locaux dans nos
communes
il y as besoin d'embaucher et donc je
suis moi plutôt favorable à garantir à
chacun un bon salaire un vrai travail
dans de bonnes conditions y compris en
réduisant le temps de travail en
permettant à tous de travailler moins
mais de travailler tous je me battrai
pour cela et c'est pour cela que je
présente ma candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
alors justement si le rassemblement de
gauche que vous prenez cette alternative
de gauche l'emportent en 2022 qui
pourrait être le premier ministre de ce
rassemblement alors là vous brûler un
petit peu les étapes d'abord on va
laisser la discussion se dérouler dans
ma formation politique la décision sera
prise le 9 mai prochain et donc j'espère
que l'ensemble de ses adhérents
soutiendront la démarche est le projet
que je pense
ensuite nous présenterons notre
programme aux français et nous
présenterons l'équipe avec laquelle
j'aspire à pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre le projet pour la
france ce qui sera important pour moi et
c'est aussi important que le programme
c'est le pacte de confiance que je
souhaite pouvoir construire avec les
français il y as besoin de rétablir une
confiance dans nos concitoyens avec la
politique et ceux qui gouvernent et donc
je souhaite pouvoir instaurer un pacte
de confiance qui garantit un lien direct
entre nos concitoyens les électeurs et
ceux qui dirigent le pays et ça c'est
déterminant c'est la construction d'une
nouvelle république qui garantira à
chacun des pouvoirs beaucoup plus
importants pour agir sur leur vie fabien
roussel merci beaucoup pour cette grande
interview accordée à rtl france
merci à vous et merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi une grande interview que vous
pouvez retrouver en replay sur nos
réseaux sociaux et notre site internet
arte france point tv merci de votre
attention et à très bientôt
où
[Musique]